[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تجري كلنا من الولايات المتحده وروسيا
اليوم اختبارات واسعه نطاق لانظمه الانذار
في حالات الطوارئ روسيا والولايات المتحده
تختبان انظمه الانذار في وقت واحد على ما
يدل ذلك بولندا واوكرانيا تصلان مرحله
حرجه والكرملين لن تخدعونا بقوانينكم
وانتم تستمرون بعدائنا الشيك تحدد موعد
انضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
واوروبا ترحب موسكو تطلق وحشا نوويا جديدا
يرد الجميل للرئيس الصيني فيما العين
الروسيه ترقب بكين عن كذب نائب ياباني
يغضب بلاده ويلتقي مسؤولي الكريم بخطوات
متسارعه السعوديه واسرائيل الى اين
الاحداث تشتعل في النيجر مجددا واصابع
الاتهام تشير الى دلوعه اوروبا
يقصد فرنسا
الكرملين يكشف لعبه واشنطن قالها العرب
قديما الحرب اولها شكوى وانسطها نجوى
واخرها بلوى وبلوى الاوكران في ايقاف
الدعم الامريكي وبعد اعلان هذا التراجع
الامريكي جاء الدور على الكرملين الذي اكد
ان واشنطن ستواصل انخراطها في الصراع
الاوكراني على الرغم من قانون التمويل في
الكونغرس الذي اسقط بندعم كييف وتوقع
الكريملين تراجع الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
مع مرور الوقت اي ان هذا التراجع لم يدرى
ماذا على عيني الدب الروسي ولن تنطلع
عليهم هذه الحيله وفق التعبير الكرملين
تراجع امريكي يقابله تقدم اوروبي حيث قال
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيفوريل ان الاتحاد سيقدم
تسهيلات ماليه لاوكرانيا بقيمه خمسه
مليارات يورو في الفتره المقبله واضاف
بوريخ خلال اجتماع عقده وزراء الاوروبيون
في كييف ان اقوى التزام امني يمكن تقديمه
هو منحها العضويه في الاتحاد في ذات
السياق دع وزير الخارجيه التشيكيه الى بدء
المفاوضات حول انضمام اوكرانيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي باسرع ما يمكن واضاف انه
يجب اطلاق المفاوضات هذا الخريف او في
مطلع العام المقبل اما في بريطانيا فكشف
مسؤول عسكري رفيع المستوى لصحيفه التلغراف
ان لندن نقلت الى جميع الاسلحه التي
يمكنها توفيرها ولم يعد لديها اسلحه
لارسالها ودع المسؤول العسكري الدول
الاخرى للتدخل والتحمل المزيد من العب
ليدخل البيت الابيض الامريكي على الخط
باعلانه ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ناقش
عبر الهاتف مع الحلفاء استمرار ارسال
المساعدات لاوكرانيا مع قاده المانيا
وبريطانيا وايطاليا وكندا كل يبحث عن دعم
اخر لاوكرانيا بدا تعصر التسول بعيدا عن
ازمه اوكرانيا وفي ظل الاوضاع المتوتره
بين القطبين اعلنت الولايات المتحده
وروسيا تفعيل انظيمتيهما للطوارئ والانذار
اللاسلكي معا لكن الدولتين طمانه
المواطنين بان ذلك مجرد اجراء روتيني
لاختبار مدى جاهزيه الانظمه حيث اهبت
وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه بالمواطنين التزام
الهدوء وعدم القلق هل نفض الغبار عن اجهزه
الانذار لاقوى دولتين معا يدل على اقتراب
تلك الحرب المنتظره سنترك الاجابه لكم
وقبل ان تكتبوا اجاباتكم اليكم المصدر
[موسيقى]
65 عسكريا بين قتيل وجريح على محاور
القتال مع اسقاط 58 طائره مسيره وتدمير
عشرات الاليات والمعدات العسكريه والعهده
على المصدر كما تشاهدونه امامكم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تكبيده قوات كييف خسائر
بنحو 665 عسكريا بين قتيل وجريح خلال
الساعات الاربع والعشرين الماضيه على
محاور القتال
واضافت الوزاره في بيان ان الجيش الروسي
صدى سبعه هجمات اوكرانيه على محاور وجنوب
الاوكرانيه يواصل تمدده الى الجيران حيث
قال وزير الخارجيه البولنديز ان العلاقه
البولنديه الاوكرانيه دخلت مرحله حرجه وان
استعادتها تتطلب جهودا جباره هل خسرت بذلك
جارتها الحليفه بولن على ذكر جيران
اوكرانيا فقد اعلنت بولندا بالاشتراك مع
كييف عن اتفاق حول ممر تجاري جديد لنقل
الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى العالم في ظل تعنت
روسيا حول العوده لاتفاق الحبوب الامميه
عبر البحر الاسود والمشاكل التي سببتها
وفره الحبوب الاوكرانيه باسواق تلك الدول
بحسب روترز هل حان وقت تنفيذ الروس لبعضهم
باستهداف اي سفن في البحر الاسود هنا تعود
بنا الاحداث الى روسيا حيث ذكرت صحيفه
نيويورك ان روسيا بصدد اختبار وحش نووي
جديد هذا الوحش هو صاروخ مجنح فرط صوتي
لمحرك نووي من طراز بوريفيست نيك يستطيع
التحليق الى مسافه غير محدوده ويمتلك قدره
خارقه على اجتياز وضرب الدفاعات الجويه
لازلنا في روسيا حيث ينوي بوتين رد الجميل
لنظيره الصيني الذي زار موسكو مؤخرا وذلك
باعلان متحدث الكرملين ان الرئيس بوتين
سيجري زياره الى الصين تلبيه لدعوه الزعيم
الصيني لحضور منتدى حزام واحد طريق واحد
لننتقل الى اليابان حيث فاجا النائب
الياباني بلاده بزياره خاطفه الى موسكو
التقى خلال هذه مسؤولنا روس وهي اول زياره
معروفه لنائب ياباني منذ هجوم روسيا على
اوكرانيا العام الماضي وتاتي زياره سوزوكي
بعض انضمام اليابان الى حلفائه الغربيين
في فرض يعقوبات على موسكو بسبب الصراع
لتدين طوكيو هذه الزياره بغضب غير مسبوق
الاحداث والتطورات
افادت وسائل اعلام عبريه بان وزير
الاتصالات الاسرائيلي
الرياض للمشاركه في مؤتمر دولي واشار
الاعلام العبري الى ان من المتوقع ان يلقي
الوزير كرعي خلال مؤتمر البريد العالمي
كلمه امام وز راء الاتصالات وممثلين لكافه
دول العالم والسؤال الاهم الى اين يا ارض
الحرمين هل تقف فرنسا وراءه قتلت 29 جنديا
في هجوم شنه اكثر من 100 مسلح على قوات
للجيش بالنيجر باستخدام عبوات ناسفه
وعربات انتحاريه ويعد هذا الهجوم هو
الاكثر دمويه منذ الاطاحه بالرئيس محمد
بازوم في يوليو الماضي
[موسيقى]